مع هتافات المشيعين الغاضبين
خرج موكب تشييع الشهيد عبد الفتاح خروشه
منفذ هجوم حواره من منزله في مخيم عسكر
شرقيه نابلس ذهب الشهيد وترك خلفه ما
يواسي افراد عائلته
حفظهم المصاحف الحمد لله رب العالمين
الحمد لله فضل الله
هذا اكبر ترك تركوا لاولاده
وخلال التشييع اعترض افراد من الامن
الفلسطيني موكب الشهيد واعتدوا على
المشيعين في نابلس
لكن الاجهزه الامنيه قالت في بيان ان تدخل
افراد الامن كان بهدف اعاده الجثمان الى
سياره الاسعاف بعد قيام شبان بانزالهم
خلافا لما كان متفقا عليه مع عائلته بشان
خط سير موكب التشييع
بدورها تبنت كتائب القسام هجوم حواره
واكدت انه ياتي في اطار الرد على جرائم
الاحتلال ومستوطنه تبني كتاب القسام من
العمليه الفدائيه في حواره تؤكد ان
المقاومه حاضره للرد على جرائم الاحتلال
وما جازره المختلفه عن احتلال لن يستطيع
ان يوقف المد الثوري المتعاظم في كل مدن
ومخيمات وقرى الضفه الغربيه بالرغم من هذه
المجازر
وفي مدينه جنين ومخيمها دور صاص مئات
المقاومين في موكب تشييع خمسه شهداء من
فتح والجهاد الاسلامي وحماس
استشهدوا برصاص جيش الاحتلال وهم يدافعون
عن الشهيد خروشه خلال العمليه العسكريه في
المخيم
وردا على التصعيد العسكري الاسرائيلي الذي
خلف منذ بدايه هذا العام اكثر من 70 شهيدا
وجرحى من مختلف الاعمار في مدن الفلسطينيه
عده دعت حركات المقاومه الفلسطينيه الى
تصعيد المقاومه والرد على العمليات
الاسرائيليه وحملت اسرائيل مسؤوليه اي
تصعيد ضد المدنيين الفلسطينيين وقد عمى
الاضراب معظم مدن الضفه الغربيه من جنين
شمالا حتى الخليل جنوبا حدادا على ارواح
الشهداء السته في جنين بالتزامن مع تشييع
الشهداء الى مثواهم الاخير
هنا وريت جتامين لشهداء العمليه العسكريه
الاسرائيليه في جنين عمليه يتوقع كثير من
الفلسطينيين ان تعقبها عمليات اخرى خصوصا
في ظل عدم وجود تحرك دولي ومع تصريحات
مسؤولين في الحكومه الاسرائيليه طالبت
بمحو بعض البلدات الفلسطينيه عن الوجود
سمير ابو شماله الجزيره من مخيم الجنين
فلسطين